kiev ukraine is under siege tonight
russian troops have entered the city
joining me now is fiatoslav yorush a
member of the ukrainian parliament and
former campaign advisor to president
zielinski
fiat you went viral for brandishing an
ak-47 vowing to fight for your country
russian forces
are now inside the city
what's next for you
the battle is happening everywhere now
in kiev i mean i'm hearing plenty of
shooting happening on the streets and
believe me i'm not the only member of
parliament who is
joining the fight yesterday we were just
planning and bringing guns to try and
give it to everyone who wants to join in
the battle and yesterday we had
encouraged the city north the city we
pushed them out and uh now no this night
will not be indifferent they're just
using the night
to try and uh surprise and overwhelm
everything but in reality they are
overwhelmed because kiev is a city of a
million millions of people and they are
fighting back as as they have been
fighting back for the last 48 hours
so we are very confident as far as the
reality that everybody here wants to
defend with their country
and their city to the end
seats we understand that
there are thousands upon thousands
of your fellow countrymen who've made
their way to makeshift shelters
we've seen all the pictures from the
underground we've seen people taking
their pets and as much food as they can
carry we all also understand that
internet has been cut in
large parts of the country
along with food shortages and gasoline
shortages throughout the land as well is
that accurate
well we are seeing the reality of
russian occupation continue that is
misery that is people losing everything
they have that is death and destruction
we've seen plenty of civilian targets
that russians have destroyed persons
have killed i mean we
[Music]
this is no end of misery all around i
mean and second
the reality is the images and the
information coming in is so very
it's very hard to discern which is not
very hard to exactly point to the react
on the ground but again as far as key is
concerned we have proven our mantle
yesterday before that and this night
should be no different we basically have
various units operating in the city to
try and again showcase the russians that
they are
they they aren't welcome here and the
ambition is their president to destroy
my state the largest state in europe
shall not succeed
now seattle
we've showing some video right now
that you sent us you say these are
russian
pows
have they revealed anything about their
what their objectives were what they
thought the mission was coming in
to ukraine
at least the ow is not just in key and
cpws from all over ukraine again it's
not just battlefield happening right now
there are battles in the south of
ukraine in the east of ukraine in the
north of ukraine and uh
the russians are send basically sending
cruz
cruise missiles to to hit various cities
in ukraine again everywhere around the
country so as far as getting some of
their units and we we had a whole
platoon of their reconnaissance to this
unit give up in the north of the country
and
become prisons prisoners of war so we
are getting a lot of that uh reports a
lot of that information that you say
they have different stories from what
we're getting from the media i haven't
talked with them personally but the
reality is again this is a mass invasion
in which a lot of russians are dying a
lot of russians are getting killed a lot
of russians beginning to become
prisoners and they claim the that from
the russian um
from the russian chiefs of the army that
they have lost
they have lost nobody as ridiculous as
they come ukrainian has already compiled
compilation videos in response to
showcase the russians that
they are
losing everywhere in ukraine
uh the sense uh from american media
is that uh this was kind of inevitable
that it was inevitable that russia was
going to
come into
kiev did you think it was inevitable and
what could have been done to prevent
this
well the reality
that reality is very simple uh
if
uh
if there were any kind of uh we first
the weapons second uh we we destroying
russian weaponry russian troops with the
american weapons very successfully so we
thank for everything we got and we are
definitely designing for as much of it
as possible because now nothing is too
much as far as fighting one of the
world's largest armies that's first
second on the matter of the question of
what
could have been done to prevent this a
lot
lots of ideas come to mind to be honest
with you because
russia doesn't want to try involve
itself with estonia which as has big
russian population just across the
border
uh and uh still because nato membership
doesn't want to do that the point for us
is that's why we pursue nato membership
because that's the only guarantee of
security we can get as far as russia is
concerned
fiat
we hope you're very i know you have to
move locations because uh you personally
feel like you're under threat in the
last hour so we're going to let you go
but stay safe out there thank you so
much for your voice